joining us now with reaction is Arvind
law school professor emeritus Alan
Dershowitz we just call you dersh by the
way professor but is that okay that's
like your nickname that's alright
production Nick my students have called
me that my students I love that for
years we're just copying the students
son here the author of the new book
trumped up how criminalization of
political differences in dangers
democracy he joins us from San Francisco
and in Dallas
the man who investigated President Bill
Clinton former independent counsel and
judge and SG Ken Starr let's start with
you judge Starr we're gonna get into
these texts and in just a moment but a
quick reaction from both of you from
what we saw tonight and Alabama looks
like a point one percent victory but
nonetheless a victory for a Democrat
Doug Jones a judge star is this a
rejection a repudiation in any way of
the Trump agenda or is this
Sooey generous to keep it in the
legalistic terms I love that Sooey
generous exactly it is a one-off all
politics are local but this was
especially a local election just given
the issues that popped up so yes it's a
one-time election and I love the
suggestion that the senator elect if he
holds on to the victory we heard that
report is is already a lame duck look
Alabama is a heavily Republican state
and judge Moore was just viewed
obviously as a severely flawed candidate
and look at the turnout the turnout was
suppressed let's go to presser
Dershowitz on this professor people were
you know we're saying it was impossible
for a Democrat to win these allegations
were raised against of course Roy Moore
he didn't really have a great refutation
in the one major interview he did with
Sean Hannity then you had Richard Shelby
the respected Republican mainstream
senator come out yesterday hitting more
friends of mine in Alabama said that did
a lot to suppress voter turnout in the
Republican Party for more and a lot of
people just stayed home well this was
not a win for the Democrats it was a
loss for judge Moore it was very very
personal it was a referendum on Harvey
Weinstein
on all the allegations that are nast
swirling around so many people in the
world and more could not survive the
accusations that were leveled against
them this tells us nothing that would
allow us to predict till other elections
and other states will go it is a
completely one-off I completely agree
with my friend Ken Starr on this one all
right we're gonna hear from Doug Jones
in just a moment and we're gonna have to
go to that one when he speaks but let's
go to you a judge Starr on these texts
from Peter struck do they change your
mind about the special counsels
investigation
Muller's team more tainted after reading
these or less of course it's it's
outrageous and it really does go to to
Bob Muller's judgment you need to
assemble a team when you're talking
about investigating the pros the United
States that really is above reproach
these folks have their First Amendment
rights so let them say what they want to
say but all right deeply sorry we have
to go right to Doug Jones in Alabama his
victory speech pardoned it part of the
interruption